anfang november wird der pilot andrés
martinez direkt vor dem hessischen
staatstheater in wiesbaden überfallen
am helllichten vormittag haben zwei
männer den gebürtigen kolumbianer mitten
in der stadt aus gemeinsam mit einem
passanten keine ein der täter schnappen
doch die staatsanwaltschaft lässt den
kriminellen schon am nächsten tag wieder
laufen ja ich bin so sauer diese stets
weil es gibt keine gerechtigkeit es ist
es ist einfach unfassbar unglaublich das
war passiert weil ein auto kaufen will
hebt martin es 13.000 euro bei seiner
bank ab gangster beobachten ihm dabei
auf dem parkplatz stechen sie ihm
unbemerkt ein loch in den reifen
wenig später muss martinez notgedrungen
anhalten
plötzlich nähert sich ein mann der reißt
die tür auf cloud jacke mit dem geld und
übergibt sie blitzschnell einem zweiten
täter
es kommt zum handgemenge der zweite
täter droht mit einem messer und türmte
der beute den anderen aber kann martinez
zusammen mit einem passanten festhalten
bis die polizei kommt der leben riskiert
von nix wohl gar nichts bei 24 stunden
war diese martinez kann es nicht fassen
die staatsanwaltschaft lässt den täter
laufen obwohl der keinen festen wohnsitz
in deutschland hat für viele wiesbaden
ein echter justizskandal ohne festen
wohnsitz verstehe ich nicht über den
laufen lassen kann wenn es ganz klar ist
dass das an diesem abend passiert ist
aber ich versteh ich nicht und wenn in
so einer situation unser rechtssystem
nicht in der lage ist einen täter zu
fassen festzuhalten und eventuellen den
haftbefehl auszuüben habe ich das gefühl
das stimmt etwas nicht von der
staatsanwaltschaft wiesbaden will sich
niemand vor der kamera äußern
für die strafverfolger ist die ganze tat
nur halb so schlimm
im hinblick auf den dringenden
tatverdacht der sich lediglich auf einen
einfachen diebstahl bezog wurde der
beschuldigte aus verhältnismäßigkeit
gründen entlassen
der beschuldigte hatte unter dieser
prämisse nach damaliger bewertung
lediglich eine geldstrafe zu erwarten
das alles soll ein einfacher diebstahl
gewesen sein
unglaublich empörend weil es scheint ja
eine vorbereitet hat gewiss gewesen zu
sein auch mit dem stich in den reifen
und dann die müssen ihnen eigentlich
erfolg haben um zu wissen was überhaupt
so viel bargeld hat ein schlechtes
signal dass es genau das signal dass ihr
ausgesendet wird verbrechen lohnt sich
also man kann genauso weitermachen
familie martinez hat nicht nur geld
verloren sondern auch das vertrauen in
die deutsche justiz für sie steht fest
die beiden kriminellen haben sich die
beute geteilt und halten längst nach
neuen opfern ausschau